A briefcase full of
cash is a trope so common that even TV Tropes,
a website dedicated to cataloguing cinematic
cliches, requests that users only mention
“exceptions, parodies and subversions”.
While you’d expect something so ridiculous
to be an invention, or at the very least an
exaggeration, of Hollywood, it appears that
paying for things with a big ol’ stack of
cash stored conveniently inside of a briefcase
is more common than you’d think.
In fact, during our research we very easily
found many dozens of documented examples of
exactly this happening, some of the more interesting
of which we’d like to share now.
While you’d expect exchanges involving briefcases
full of cash to be near-exclusively done by
seedy underworld types, that’s not really
the case.
Before we continue, yes, that was a briefcase
pun.
For example, in 2013 George Clooney (yes,
that George Clooney) gathered up 14 of his
closest friends and presented each one of
them with a briefcase containing exactly $1
million in cash.
The star explained to his stunned friends
that the money was a gift to thank them for
their support when he was just a struggling
actor, reportedly stating:
Listen, I want you guys to know how much you’ve
meant to me, and how much you mean to me in
my life.
I came to L.A., I slept on your couch.
I’m so fortunate in my life to have all
of you, and I couldn’t be where I am today
without all of you.
So, it was really important to me that, while
we’re still all here together, that I give
back…
I know we’ve all been through some hard
times, some of you are still going through
it…
You don’t have to worry about your kids;
you don’t have to worry about school; you
don’t have to worry about paying your mortgage.
According to one of the recipients of the
money, Rande Gerber, Clooney went as far to
pay all of the associated taxes on the gift
so that each man got to keep 100% of the cash
for themselves.
George Clooney is just that kind of guy apparently.
On the other end of the financial spectrum,
you have Luq Mughal, a student at the University
of Utah who in 2014 paid a $2000 tuition bill
with two thousand one dollar bills stored
inside of a briefcase.
This act was to protest the soaring cost of
higher education in the United States.
Sticking with protesting, there are many examples
of people taking advantage of the U.S. law
that dictates that any debt (regardless of
size) that the debtor attempts to settle with
cold hard cash cannot be refused.
The specific law is U.S. Code Title 31 §5103,
which states in part,
United States coins and currency (including
Federal reserve notes and circulating notes
of Federal reserve banks and national banks)
are legal tender for all debts, public charges,
taxes, and dues…
Thus, if you have a particularly huge bill
and wish to pay in relatively small denominations
just to annoy or otherwise waste the time
of a business, a briefcase full of $1 bills,
or perhaps a barrel full of pennies, is a
great way to go about it.
Although, just as effective at annoying people
is that time a man paid a $137 traffic ticket
with individual dollar bills folded into origami
pigs stored inside of donut boxes.
(See: What Started the Cops Eating Donuts
Stereotype?)
Getting back to briefcases full of money,
in the early 1990s Black Sabbath guitarist
Tony Iommi was arrested in Sacramento for
non-payment of child support while the band
was on tour.
After being informed that his bail had been
set at $75,000, the band’s managers sent
a lawyer with a briefcase containing that
amount of money in cash to the jail in order
to expedite his release so the night’s show
didn’t have to be canceled.
An individual known for making extensive use
of briefcases full of money is controversial
boxing promoter Don King.
Specifically, it’s claimed that King would
often use just this tactic to get young boxers
to take him on as a manager.
At the sight of such a large amount of cash,
this would invariably make the boxer less
hesitant to sign a contract with sometimes
wildly unfavourable terms for the young athlete.
On one occasion, King reportedly even managed
to convince the late, great Muhammad Ali to
drop a court case by having an associate deliver
a briefcase containing $50,000 in cash to
the boxer.
Despite being owed over $1 million after King
shortchanged him on his winnings in a 1980
boxing match, Ali agreed to drop a case he
likely would have easily won upon laying eyes
on the money.
Needless to say, Ali’s lawyers who weren’t
around when said briefcase full of cash deal
was presented were none too pleased when they
found out what had happened.
In the world of soccer, this tactic was reportedly
used (unsuccessfully) to convince an, at the
time, 15 year old John Obi Mikel to sign with
a team he failed to recall during a later
interview with The Sun.
Mikel claims he was initially tempted to sign
the contract on the spot thanks to the briefcase
full of cash, but wisely changed his mind
and decided to delay to think it over.
Moving on to other forms of entertainment,
briefcases full of cash have commonly featured
as prizes in gameshows and, on one notable
occasion in 2005, a documentary called Reversal
of Fortune.
In regards to the latter, the subject of the
documentary, a homeless man called Ted Rodrigue,
was gifted $100,000 by producers just to see
what he’d do with the money.
Rather than simply giving the money to Rodrigue,
they instead decided that it’d look better
for cameras to hide it inside the briefcase
which they arranged for Rodrigue to find while
dumpster diving.
Understandably, Rodrigue initially wanted
nothing to do with the money believing it
was linked to organised crime and had to be
assured by producers that the money was really
from them and his to keep.
For anyone interested in what happened next,
we’ve covered the documentary in more detail
in a previous article.
Moving on to the world of business, in 2013,
to drum up interest in a crowdfunding website
he’d recently invested in called FundAnything.com,
Donald Trump gave away three briefcases full
of cash to random people from the lobby of
Trump Tower in New York.
The publicity stunt, which was widely condemned
as an offensive charade by the media, featured
Trump handing out both large checks as well
as the aforementioned three briefcases full
of cash.
Certain people were also invited to reach
into an aquarium full of money to grab as
much as they could hold after sharing sob
stories with the gathered press.
Trump officially cut ties with the site less
than a year later.
Speaking of people flaunting their wealth,
boxer Floyd Mayweather Jr. has been known
to travel carrying suitcases and duffel bags
filled with sometimes millions of dollars
in cash, famously publicly stating, “When
I travel I don’t pack clothes.
I only pack Benjamins”.
Such extravagant displays of wealth are a
trademark of the boxer with Mayweather reportedly
having a standing arrangement with his bank
to have huge sums of money in cash periodically
delivered to his palatial home with the primary
purpose being to facilitate flaunting his
fabulous wealth.
Shifting focus slightly to the world of organised
crime and corruption, briefcases full of cash
are frequently alluded to in both firsthand
accounts from gangsters as well as official
police reports.
For example, a sting operation conducted by
Brazilian authorities in 2017 found that corrupt
politicians throughout the country were routinely
bribed by criminals with briefcases full of
money.
Similar accusations have also been leveled
at Russian oligarchs who’ve been accused
of bribing officials with literal briefcases
full of cash in the past.
Similarly, while scanning through autobiographical
accounts of underworld dealings from criminals,
we found multiple references to briefcases
full of cash being used to do everything from
paying off corrupt officials to settling debts
and fostering new criminal alliances.
As for why the briefcase seems to be the go-to
method of transport for bundles of cash, the
answer seems to be quite simply that a nondescript
briefcase, holdall or bag is a fairly innocuous
item that generally doesn’t arouse suspicion
when carried in public.
Additionally, in specific regards to briefcases,
unlike backpacks and other kinds of bag, many
come with combination locks as a standard
feature.
Couple this with the fact they’re lightweight,
solidly built, somewhat (or in some cases
completely) weather proof, and invariably
of a fairly uniform size, and a briefcase
seems like an obvious choice for moving large
amounts of cash.
It’s also worth noting that some briefcases,
like those produced by Hollywood favorite
ZERO Halliburton (appearing in over 200 movies
and TV shows to date as the go-to way to store
bundles of cash on camera) are specifically
designed to carry valuables and as a result
posses features like padding and a hardened
exterior, making them even more suited for
the task of carrying bundles of cash.
So to conclude, the idea of people paying
for things with a briefcase full of money
isn’t just an invention of Hollywood and
is something that actually happens with surprising
regularity in the real world.
Now, if you’ll excuse us we’re going to
go and research if any criminal has ever robbed
a bank carrying away sacks with large dollar
signs printed on them.
There
is actually at least one confirmed case from
history of a criminal committing a crime while
holding a sack with a dollar sign on it.
According to a police report obtained by The
Smoking Gun in April of 2015, a man called
David Eli Lingafelter robbed a Subway restaurant
in Washington and upon being apprehended,
was found to have stored all of his ill-gotten
gains inside of a small white bag he’d hastily
drawn a dollar sign on the outside of.